-The charades champion.
-Right?
-Yes! We are the champs.
-Not deserved at all.
-No, not at all. No, not at all.
But, by the way,
you kept saying,
"Hey, we're going to come back.
We're going to come back."
And what did we do?
-Exactly.
-Came back. Unbelievable.
Yeah, I want to talk about this,
"Dear Evan Hansen."
-Yeah.
-You're coming back to Broadway.
-I am.
-Are you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Is it like riding a bike?
Do you go, "Oh, I know how to
do this -- Broadway"?
-A little bit.
It's more -- So,
if that's riding a bike,
this is kind of like
getting on a motorcycle.
-Oh, it is?
-Yeah, a little bit,
just because I haven't been --
I haven't run in
a show long term,
consistently since I was 12,
and that was before
my voice changed.
I was only doing
four shows a week then.
Now I'm doing eight.
-I can just imagine it's just so
straining on your voice to do --
-Especially --
Yeah, this show is
not kind to most of
the performers in it.
And I'm playing Jared.
I'm very, very excited.
And --
-Wow! When does it begin?
When do you --
-I open July 19th.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-That's soon.
It is soon.
-That whole cast of
"Stranger Things" can all sing.
-A good portion, yes.
-It's, like, a talented cast.
-Some of them much better
than I can, yeah.
-Remember, I think, Season 1,
do you remember
that you were doing this thing
that all the rest of
the cast was getting annoyed by.
You kept singing, "Oh, my God"?
-[ Laughs ]
-Do you remember this?
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
Yeah, that one.
-Yeah, yeah,
You kept saying, "Oh, my God."
And everyone was like,
"Will you stop saying that?"
But that was your
catchphrase at the time.
-At the time, yeah.
I wanted something that, like,
they'd hear just in the distance
and they'd be like,
"Oh, there he is."
-Yeah.
Can you do it one more time?
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
I was better at it
when I was like 14.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I was better --
-No, it's so good.
That should be --
Someone should sample that
and put it in a song.
-Well, it's better when
The Roots can
accompany you with it.
-Can you do a little bit of a...
♪♪
-Yeah.
-[ Humming ]
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-Yeah.
-Yeah, of course. It's perfect.
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-Yeah.
That's what we need, yeah.
-In the show,
I guess I got to see
"NeverEnding Story," of course.
-Yeah.
-We'll get to that.
"Running Up That Hill,"
by the way.
How about that?
-Right?
-That's taking
a life of its own.
-It's great for me.
-Yeah.
-Because it's replaced
"NeverEnding Story."
-Oh, because
that was your thing.
-Oh, yeah. That was --
-We've done stuff with you on
the show where like,
"Do you mind doing that?"
But now it's on Sadie's --
-Now it's sucks for Sadie.
Yeah. But I'm in the clear
for a bit.
It's awesome.
-Did you like hearing it,
like, when you're
doing it on the show?
-I love doing it on the show.
-Yeah.
-Gabby, who plays Suzie,
is just awesome and incredible.
And she's a Broadway kid,
as well.
-Really?
-Yeah, she was
in "Fun Home" for like --
I just saw her.
Like three or four years,
she ran in that show,
which is a really long time,
especially for a kid actor.
Yeah, but she's great.
And when she came on set,
we like heard it like
10 minutes before we shot.
And then we, like,
got a harmony track set up
and all that jazz, yeah.
-It was greatest.
-It was fun.
-When Sadie was on the show,
she was --
I was talking about Vecna
was the new character
who has, like, kind of
taken off a little bit.
-Catch up.
-Yeah, that show,
"Stranger Things," yeah.
Here's Vecna.
And she said she had a very --
-There he is.
-I go, "Was he frightening
on the set?
And she goes, "Actually, no,
because I had --
My first time I met Vecna,
he was eating a sandwich."
-Yeah.
-Kind of takes
all the frightening out
as he's eating a hoagie.
Just chomping on a hoagie.
-It reminds -- I saw him once
during filming of Volume 1.
I saw him at -- Like one time.
And we were doing, like --
I was in costume,
and we were doing 3-D scans.
Like, you have to go into your
room and, like --
They, like, take a bunch of
pictures all around,
'cause there's a lot of
animation in the show,
especially this year.
And so it was kind of, like,
a little line of, like,
the cast, like, in costume,
like, they went -- whenever they
had free time during filming.
And I saw --
-Vecna?
-Yeah.
I saw Vecna sitting there.
And I looked over.
I was like,
"Hi. it's great to see you."
I hadn't seen him
since the table read.
And he was just like,
"Yeah, how are you?
It's good to see you."
Like, just in a lawn chair,
like, feet up,
and, like, whole half, like,
done up in Vecna gear.
It is unsettling
and just bonkers, yeah.
-From the waist down wearing,
like, sweatpants?
-Yeah, pretty much, I think.
I think,
if I remember correctly.
I was kind of drawn towards
his messed-up face.
But --
-And he's just talking to you
like he's not Vecna?
-Yeah, it was like,
"How are you?"
He's like,
"It's good to see you."
Like, he looked exhausted.
-That reminds me.
We did a bit,
The Roots and I did,
at Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade.
And we're on the float
and we're on a bus.
You know, they put all the
people that are going to be on
the floats on a bus
before you go on the float.
And, so, it was me and The Roots
and Ronald McDonald.
And it's just great.
The guy was so nice.
But he's dressed like
Ronald McDonald.
-But he's Ronald McDonald.
-Yeah, and he's having
a normal conversation,
like, drinking a coffee.
He's like, "Yeah, man,
the subway was crazy."
I go, "I can't have --
You're Ronald McDonald."
-Did you laugh?
-No.
No, I just had to tell him,
"You've got to stop,
because, like, you're dressed
like Ronald McDonald."
-I wouldn't have been
able to breathe.
-Had a full-on hour-and-a-half
conversation
with Ronald McDonald.
And we were all freaking out.
We're like, "Oh, my gosh."
And then, James --
-Of course you have, like,
the -- you're doing the parade.
That's pretty
nerve-racking, right?
-Yeah.
We were nervous about that.
But then we were all kind of
just freaking out that
Ronald McDonald
was on the thing.
And we're like -- And James
was about to come on the bus,
and we're like,
"Oh, James is going freak out
that we're talking to
Ronald McDonald."
And James came on the bus.
Do you remember
what he said, Quest?
-Yeah. He was like,
"What's up, Ron?"
[ Laughter ]
-He said, "What's up, Ron?"
like he's one of our friends.
It was like, we're sitting
talking to Ronald McDonald.
James is going -- And he goes,
"What's up, Ron?"
Like him and Ronald McDonald
hang out or something.
-What is it -- What are, like,
the daily issues
of Ronald McDonald?
Like, what are like the --
-Putting curlers
in the wig, yeah.
He's got kind of
a curled hairstyle.
-Yeah.
-He's got big shoes.
-Beautifully coiffed.
-He's got a coif,
Ronald McDonald.
Got the yellow jodhpurs.
-It's a lot.
Shoes are a bit big.
-Shoes are giantly big.
He's dressed like a clown.
-Sure.
-He's a pretty famous clown.
I mean, he has to take, like,
a car to wherever he's going.
He can't take
public transportation.
-No.
-You know?
-I guess not, yeah.
I never thought about the
struggles of being
Ronald McDonald,
though, I go to say.
-There's got to be a documentary
there somewhere.
-Yeah.
-What goes on --
I mean, it's like Vecna.
It's like Vecna.
The poor guy
can't even eat a sandwich.
-He can't go anywhere.
-He can't be on his cellphone,
checking his voicemail.
Can't go to Starbucks.
He's like, "Ah, I'm Vecna."
-"No, I got big [bleep] to do."
-Yeah. "I got
big things to do," yeah.
Season 4, Volume 2
comes out this Friday.
-Yeah.
-I know you've done --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've done a great job
not giving any spoilers away,
and I'm not
going to get you in trouble.
-Thank you.
-I just want to --
This is your wardrobe.
-Yeah. That's great. That's fun.
-Yeah. Okay, so I'm assuming
that there is some --
there's a big finale.
-Yeah, as you can see.
-Yes.
There's also -- Here's you --
-There's a picture.
I look so cute
in that picture, don't I?
-You look so cute here.
Yeah. Oh, my God.
This should be
the poster for it.
-That's the new Instagram
bio pic right there.
-But when you're doing this,
you go, "Okay, Oh, my gosh.
We have -- They go, "Oh, there's
two new episodes coming out."
And you go, "Yeah."
They go, "Oh, two? That's it?"
And you go, "No."
Every episode is like -- The
first episode's like two hours?
-The first episode --
so eighth episode is,
I think,
probably an hour and a half.
But Episode 9 is getting
close to 2 1/2 hours.
It's a movie.
-That is a movie
right there coming out.
-I know.
-You did a movie.
They're all kind of
beautifully done.
-They're basically just --
It's nine movies, practically.
All of them are close to
an hour and a half.
All of them over an hour.
-They're so good.
And it's all
starting to pay off.
And everything works
and it's really cool.
-Yeah, we definitely --
You learn a lot.
-You learn a lot, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And it's a scary and it's good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Gaten Matarazzo in
Season 4 of "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this.
-Hey, Steve.
-Did you guys see this?
-How many phones do you have?
-Someone was murdered.
-Uh, two. Why?
-Uh, technically three if you
count Keith's in the back.
-Yeah, three works.
-What are you doing?
Whoa! What are you --
-My pile!
-No, no, no, no! Not my tapes!
Dude! What are you doing, man?
-Setting up
base of operations here.
-Base of operations?
-Stop. Get off of that.
-No. I need it.
-Need it for what?
-Looking up Eddie's friends'
phone numbers.
-Oh, Eddie.
Your new best friend, Eddie,
who you think
is cooler than me because
he plays your nerdy game?
-Yes! I never said that.
-Seriously, you guys,
maybe on a Monday,
you can play around in here like
toddlers, but it's Saturday.
It's our busiest day.
-Alright, look.
Robin, I totally empathize, but
this cannot wait until Monday?
-What? Because calling all of
Eddie's friends is an emergency?
-Correct!
-Uh, do you want me
to strangle him
or do you want to do that?
-We could take turns.
-Yes, it's fun.
Gaten Matarazzo, everybody.
Season 4, Volume 2 of
"Stranger Things"
is on Netflix this Friday.
And you can see Gaten in
"Dear Evan Hansen"
on Broadway starting July 19th.